papa tu es quelqu'un d'obstiné de bornes
et de magnac un rouspéteur psychorigide
c'est gentil ça doit être pour mon
anniversaire je sais qu'on n'arrive pas
à se voir autant qu'on aimerait pouvoir
le faire mais quand on y arrive je dois
reconnaître que c'est fabuleux à
l'amitié
bienvenue à bord monsieur
c'est magnifique chez toi quel dommage
cette [ __ ] de fulminer un tout petit
bémol au paradis
notre arrangement j'y repensais loti
quoi à temps et écoute moi on a réglé sa
ya 20 ans on à faire patte les roues je
ne suis plus du tout le même homme
redevient qui tue et m on m'a contacté
pour jouer une grand-mère au nom 60 ans
aujourd'hui ses 40 ans hier ouais bien
sûr vu de dos et dans leurs noms mais
regarde le compositeur de jingles raté
une actrice vieillissante le monde dans
lequel on vit
c'est plus pour nous pourquoi billy est
un connard aussi ingrat [ __ ]
écoute moi petit chien pas te faire
[ __ ] c'est quoi ce qu'est ce que tu
fabriques fou des classes non c'est faux
quoi vous êtes venu sommes là pour
célébrer ta rationnelle intérim à curité
le bon vieux sage que tu es devenu tu
dois me parler enfin
j'aurais jamais dû vendre l'entreprise
le jour où je les vends du je me suis
sentie mourir au moins tu as d'autres
choses on ne voulait pas avoir d'enfant
quand je regarde et yakhya de super mes
enfants mon vieux
toutes ces années il a été marié à son
boulot à tétouan sas étrangers c'était
beaucoup plus qu'une simple aventure
l'audi
[Musique]
j'ai bousillé toutes les bonnes choses
et tu es la meilleure d'entre elles
ap
tu sais parfois tu dois juste profiter
de tout ce qui t'entoure
faut que tu te places
promets moi que les dix années qui
viennent seront les meilleurs de notre
vie
[Musique]
merci tu as tellement de chance toi
billy thème toujours façon dont ils
regardent
non il est trop vaniteux pour mettre ses
lunettes il vit dans un groupe
brouillonne
[Rires]